[string instrumental]
♪♪♪
PROFESSOR WHEELER:
Blenheim Palace.
It's so interesting
that apparently Her Majesty,
whenever she goes
there, always says,
"Why is your Palace
bigger than mine?'
♪♪♪
FRANK MANNION: We're at a
quintessentially British event,
Sir James,
what brings you here?
So this is an amazing place.
I've never been here before.
I've obviously
been to Blenheim,
but not to Salon Privé before.
This is the Duke
of Marlborough Award.
So Your Grace,
would you like to present Ben
with his award, please?
FRANK MANNION: Andrew,
we're at the Salon Privé.
What brings you here?
We've been before,
we've enjoyed it, I like cars
and it's a nice setting,
you know,
it's just a nice thing to do.
What's special
about British cars?
When they work?
They have a personality,
a character.
FRANK MANNION: What would you
say is the defining qualities
of being
quintessentially British?
Well, I think that
we're very friendly people.
I think we're very relaxed
and creative and I suppose
a little bit quirky.
And you think
of all the incredible things
that have come
out of this country,
from the Rolling Stones and
the Beatles to Aston Martin.
I mean, it's an absolutely
fantastic mélange
of excitement
and creativity, I think.
♪♪♪
FRANK MANNION: Our feature
documentary is called
Quintessentially British.
What does quintessentially
British mean to you?
Unique, I think, probably is
the best way to describe it.
It's very difficult
to pin down
what it means to be British.
There is something
about self-deprecation,
something about attachment
to history and tradition.
Quiet pride.
Being in a garden,
a green space.
I think of our British
sense of humor is really
what the British people turn to,
in times of trouble,
and what helps us get out of it.
I think the way we speak,
because we're full of irony,
so ironic and always saying
things we don't quite mean.
There's always "Well, what did
he mean when he said that?"
There's always that element.
I love that.
Politeness, kindness.
Stuck-up-ness.
When American friends
of mine come over here,
they often say,
"Oh you know, the English
are so friendly." And I think
to myself and I sometimes say
to them, "They're civil."
They're not really
necessarily friendly.
But you know, they're polite
in a way that you know,
in America you go
into a shop or the supermarket
and you know,
they're all over you
with this kind of,
you know, bonhomie,
which then is just switched off.
You know,
we don't overstate things.
Americans are all about these
big gestures, aren't they?
You know,
when they meet each other
and they're sort of "Oh,
it's fantastic to see you."
We're a little bit quieter,
you know, sort of assume
that it's good to see you,
but we'd really
just rather sort of get
down to talking
about what's going on.
We do like to go our own way
and do our own thing,
and listening to other people
can be difficult at times.
Yes.
We kind of have a strict sense
of formal etiquette.
But in truth,
anyone who's spent
any time with normal
British people would know
that we're basically a lot
of the time drunk.
So, we're a mass
of contradictions.
NEIL ROBINSON: I think
if you ask my wife
what the quintessential
characteristics
of an Englishmen are,
she would say good manners,
respectful behaviour,
decent standards of dress.
Perhaps she's a little old
fashioned in that.
Just being very English.
[laughs]
If the cliché of the Englishman
is his politeness,
his discretion,
his privacy, obeys the rules,
is it any wonder
that those same people
love going to the theatre
where everything is different
and the people let their hair
down and sometimes their pants.
We love the theatre,
because so many of us are
not theatrical in our lives.
And the most famous Englishman
who ever lived wrote plays,
but was an actor.
Not a king.
Not a politician.
Not an athlete.
Not a saint.
Our national hero is an actor.
Of course, other cultures
love their theater.
And everyone loves storytelling
it's a very, very basic need.
But the Brits have caught on
to it, perhaps more than most.
We've been at it a long time.
FRANK MANNION: Just do a sound
check, Ian, just--
Yes, yes, go ahead. Yup.
FRANK MANNION: Sir Ian McKellen.
You-- please, I'm not Sir.
FRANK MANNION: Okay, okay.
That's a title.
It's not a name.
Unless you're calling
everybody else Mister.
FRANK MANNION: Sure.
Okay. Ian McKellen.
Yep, yep, thank you.
I began to like Shakespeare
by going to see his plays.
Not by reading them.
Or being taught them.
He knew, it seems better
than any other writer
who ever lived,
the variety of human needs
and passions,
and desires.
That's the basis of it all
is the jealousy, the love,
the hatred, the fear.
OZ CLARKE: Shakespeare,
in one speech tells you
more about the life
of a man, from cradle to grave
than a thousand pages
of someone else's writing
could tell you.
We love tales of horror
and violence and murder
and people doing terrible
things to each other.
And Shakespeare does
them so brilliantly.
IAN MACKELLAN: He only
invented one plot for himself
in the whole of the 37 plays.
That was the last play he wrote.
All the others he pinched.
What? From history books,
from poetry books,
from other people's plays.
There was a Hamlet play
before Shakespeare wrote his.
We filmed Hamlet before
we put it onto the stage
and when we were filming it,
the Duke of Edinburgh died.
The Duke of Edinburgh dying
as we were filming a play
about a royal family
who lived in a castle.
And here we were in
the shadow of Windsor Castle,
and we were
filming the castle.
You know, the queen losing
her husband after so long.
Here we are doing a story
about a queen who
loses a husband and marries
her husband's brother.
It's hard not to see what
the connections are.
Ian McKellen was wary
of playing Hamlet
because he's 80 and Hamlet's 20.
But I thought he can respect
the language and the poetry,
but still make it his own
and make it modern.
Because whilst he's known
now as Gandalf, he's still
sort of known
for being this great,
great Shakespearean actor.
Oh, we're living in an age
when an 82 year old man
is pretending
to be a 22 year old boy
and that specific man
doing it, MacKellen.
Here we are, it's live.
And never forget,
you can never forget
when you're seeing
a Shakespeare play
that that's exactly
what you're doing.
You're seeing a play.
REPORTER: Dame Judi.
REPORTER 2: Dame Judi,
to your left please.
REPORTER 3:
Over here please, Judi.
FRANK MANNION: We were filming
with Sir Ian McKellen
with Hamlet and you of course,
played Ophelia in Hamlet
-and Hamlet--
-And Gertrude.
FRANK MANNION:
And Gertrude and Ophelia--
Not in the same production.
FRANK MANNION:
What is it
about Shakespeare that is
so quintessentially English
and beloved around the world?
I have two passions.
One is Shakespeare.
The other is trees.
And I was brought up
on Shakespeare as a little girl,
and my family used to quote it.
Reams of it, I could do
a whole play for you now.
If you like the Dream or Twelfth
Night, I could do all that.
I could do a lot
of Measure for Measure.
I could do a bit
of The Merchant of Venice.
It's a good note
to give to tired old actors
of Shakespeare is, you know
Shakespeare was an Italian?
"To be or not to be,
that's the question," I mean--
Italians, the cliche for us
who are not Italians,
is that they never stop talking.
You can say
the same of the Irish.
And talking very well.
Good talk. Not idle chatter.
But done with great flair
and imagination and metaphor
and a variety of pace
in the speaking and the hands
and the gestures
coming to it in a way
that the British wouldn't
express themselves these days.
I mean, we've had
the Victorian era to live
through to change
our collective personality,
our national personality.
But I think Shakespeare's
characters are much more what
we think of as Italian or Irish.
[jaunty keyboard instrumental]
EMMA ELWICK-BATES: My world
at the moment, we talk so much
about the provenance
of where your item is made.
And I think what's
so interesting about the Queen,
but also
the Royal Family at large,
is they've
always shopped that way.
They've always supported
the Savile Row's,
the Henry Poole's,
Prince Charles gets
his John Lobb shoes,
the Duke of Edinburgh,
a Lock & Co. cap.
And that's so important
to them to support these brands
and to give them their Royal
Warrants and I think
it's often underestimated
how important that is
and how that keeps
these businesses alive.
I have to confess that
I have never, ever been able
to afford to go to Savile Row
to buy my clothes.
But I think there is something
about precision tailoring,
genuine craftsmanship
that is an important
bit of British making tradition.
LADY CARNARVON: The sartorial
elegance, which is actually
partly seen in Downton Abbey,
is very British,
whether it's
through James Bond
or the Savile Row tailors.
I think the British
are known for it
and it's trying
to set a high bar.
And some ways, of course,
that's what His Royal Highness
Prince Philip set out to do.
He always encouraged people
to be the best
and that's
where you should aim for.
Not half tying a tie,
but tying a tie really well.
Learning how to do something
really well, you know,
looking at someone's shoes,
are they polished or not?
And I still find I look
at someone's shoes,
just glancing down
just seeing whether
they're polished or not.
My husband gave our son
a 21st birthday present
of a suit from Savile Row.
So it's that wonderful process
of choosing the fabric,
of deciding, it's of getting
measured, of getting adjusted.
That whole process and journey
is a delight to watch.
There is no other
street like Savile Row.
Through the generations it's
survived and it's survived
because of obviously the great
houses, the names that have
existed here on the Row.
We don't claim to be
in fashion at any one time,
because fashion comes and goes.
Like the tide,
it comes in and out.
Bespoke is a tailoring term
and the young will
always have a need
to create things
that are unique for them.
SIMON CUNDEY: Henry Poole
really is the founding fathers
of Savile Row and also the great
inventors of the dinner suit,
otherwise known as the Tuxedo.
It's a great honour to be
at Henry Poole and being known
for dressing some
of the great names of the past,
such as Vanderbilts,
such as J.P. Morgan,
such as Napoleon III,
such as the Tzars of Russia,
even the Emperor of Japan.
Still today, these names stand.
Winston Churchill was probably
one of our great men
that have walked in here.
And of course, he came to us
as a young, slim gentleman
and got to meet my great
grandfather and my grandfather.
And my grandfather remembered
talking about his suits
that came in for abundant
alteration cleaning
due to the cigar smoke.
And they would always find
little bits of ash
and stubs inside pockets,
which was very much
his character.
But he was apparently
a wonderful man,
even though
he was quite moody
at some points,
you know, and we did
have a little
tit for tats over bills
that were eventually sorted.
This is what
we call measure books.
So we would have
measured Winston's father,
and this is 1886
by the looks of it.
Later on in life, Winston came
to us in 1906, which is there,
and that's some
of his clothes that was made.
You'll always meet customers
and get to know them,
which is the best part
of the business.
How would you
like your pockets here?
This is the big question here.
Well, generally
I don't use them.
You know, I won't be putting
any cigars in them.
-Like Churchill.
-You should, you should.
-I should.
-Four working buttons
on the cuff? So there's
four working buttons here?
Yes please, yes.
Pleats or no pleats?
That's a very good question.
You're not strong on the thigh,
so you don't
need to have pleats.
-Right.
-Zip fly or button fly?
-Zip fly.
-I have to ask.
-Yeah.
-But for most people it's zip.
So, single-breasted,
button two, notched lapel.
So, that's your plain
weave with no colorway.
That's your pinhead,
showing the actual distances
between the two colorways.
And I probably would
put it between those two.
So, Simon, I think executive
decision, I think let's go...
-Yes.
-Let's go for this.
Yes, I think
that's a lovely one.
It perfectly works well.
It's smart casual
and dress it up, dress it down.
And also it has
a bit more character,
it has a little bit
more of the depth
in the marbling effect
with the pinhead.
So it's a good, good choice.
So when you mention Savile Row,
I immediately think
of The Beatles
and their last live performance
on the roof at number 3,
Savile Row.
Sadly a bit
before my time on the row.
There's quite
often tours that come,
they will always stop
outside the Apple building,
before they come and stop here
at number 10, Savile Row.
We're very fortunate,
we have quite an eclectic
range of customers.
Officers in the army,
to captains of industry.
And we have been known
to make the odd outfit
for heads of state.
Thankfully,
I've still got my head.
Prince William
and Prince Harry did their year
at Sandhurst and whilst
they were training there,
we were asked
to make their initial uniforms.
We received a great
accolade and the fact
that their first official
portrait was of them
wearing their uniforms
made by Dege & Skinner.
When Prince Harry married,
we were approached
and asked if we would
make the frock-coat
uniform for the Blues
and Royals,
which was his mother regiment.
Other than the people
that were measuring
and doing the fitting,
no one actually knew
who we were making it for.
We're going to be making you
a sports coat,
but a sports coat
with a difference.
This jacket here is what
we call the Bentley coat.
We've utilised the Bentley
stitching that is seen
on every car steering wheel.
And I understand that it
takes 50 man hours to make
a Bentley steering wheel.
Which is, funnily enough,
the same period
of time it takes us
to make a two piece suit,
50 to 60 man hours.
The buttons are an engraved
Bentley wheel nut that would
have been on all
the original Bentley's.
Get the rubber hammer out,
bang it, untwist it,
wheel comes off.
Bit like Formula One,
but not as quick
as Formula One these days.
♪♪♪
My full name is
Adrian Bailie Nottage Palmer
and I am the 4th Baron
of Reading.
And I'm terribly fortunate
that I am able to wear quite
a lot of my father's clothes
and indeed
my grandfather's clothes.
When I got married,
I actually wore
my grandfather's tailcoat,
which was made
in Savile Row in 1921.
Huntley & Palmers
was founded by Thomas Huntley.
The Palmers and the Huntleys
were in fact related
and as things took off,
he wrote to his cousin
and said,
"Will you come and join me?"
Huntley & Palmers
had a Royal Warrant
from every royal family
in the world.
Beat that.
I was the last member
of the family to do
what they called
a really old fashioned
apprenticeship and I always
remember when I went
to the Huntley & Palmer
factory in Huyton,
they didn't like the idea of the
boss's son coming up here.
And my first job was to get
all the chewing gum off
the floor of the lady's loo.
I swear to this day
that that lavatory
had never been so clean.
They thought I would
last about 5 minutes,
whereas in fact it took
me about 5 hours to do.
I think I'm very fortunate
because I've had my biscuit
life and then
I've had my farming life.
I was 39 when I inherited
the title from my uncle.
I always slightly assumed
that I would have inherited
the title from my father, but
sadly he died before he was 71.
I nearly always actually have
a bite to eat at lunch time
in the staff restaurant where
the food is frightfully good
and quite a bit cheaper
than upstairs.
[suspenseful
string instrumental]
FRANK MANNION: Do you
think the House of Lords
-should be abolished?
-Definitely.
The House of Commons, I think,
is the most incredible
institution on the planet.
The Lords...
Anything hereditary without
actually doing it yourself
and achieving it yourself
shouldn't be around.
I don't see why, you know, you
should get there through birth.
I think that's just ridiculous.
It's a bit outdated,
if you will.
So I've heard the House
of Lords be called
the most expensive
daycare facility
for the elderly,
with their subsidised meals
paid by the taxpayer.
But that's all okay,
I mean,
we have
the House of Commons, right?
[laughing]
I thought we were just going
to talk about some gardens here.
I haven't studied it
in great depth,
to be honest,
but it probably could
do with a bit
of modernisation.
But I quite like the décor,
so don't modernize that.
I'm quite keen
on the House of Lords.
People want to abolish it, but
basically it could be renamed
a House of Experts.
Somebody once said
to my children's mother
that I speak on every subject.
That is not true.
If, for example, there was a
big division on a health bill
amendment, I probably
wouldn't vote unless I'd spoken
to somebody
who had health knowledge.
FRANK MANNION: In the 30 years
that you've been here,
what are you most proud of?
Being able to participate,
particularly on amendments
to various bills, being able
to change the course of history.
I think you famously described
Manderston, your home,
as it has 109 rooms,
but how many rooms too many?
A hundred.
[laughing]
Yes, so funny.
First thing you get given when
you come here is a clothes peg
and then, if we're lucky,
a locker and then even luckier
still, a desk
and I've actually kept
my great-grandfather's
nameplate,
which I'm very proud of.
SIR LINDSAY HOYLE:
This is a World Heritage site,
this is an important building,
this is a working museum.
It is the people's parliament.
It is for the future
of this country.
And I believe in this building.
I believe in the fabric
of this building and I believe
in democracy and this is
the home of democracy.
Which is the Commons,
which is the Lords?
Well, the good thing
is we always know,
if you're at this end of the
building, everything's green.
If you go
to the other end, it's red.
So we have that bit
in the middle of no man's land.
Do I look in envy to the Lords?
I've got to say, it
might be a little bit grander.
It might have a little bit
more gold gilding than we have.
But the reality is,
we are the elected House,
we are the democratic House.
This is supremacy when it
comes between the two Houses.
Democracy's never perfect,
we will all find fault,
but if you're going to find one
democracy that people want
to copy, it's this one and can I
stand by what I represent here?
Absolutely.
Am I proud
of the Westminster democracy?
Yes, of course
and I'm so pleased there are
so many parliaments
around the world
that's based on this democracy.
And that matters to me
and it matters the role
that we played
around the world
in ensuring democracy
comes first.
The Westminster model,
I think by far, yes,
I'm going to say, it's
the best model that we've got.
Part of my family,
is not only my wife, daughter
and the grandchildren, but
it's also the pets, isn't it?
You know, Boris the parrot
thinks he's a politician.
He loves coming to Parliament.
He shouts, "Order,
order, lock the doors."
Betty, a Patterdale Terrier,
who wants to keep charge
of everything and of course,
I've got Maggie the tortoise
and why's she called Maggie?
She's not for turning
and she's got a hard shell.
So of course as you realize,
all the pets are
named after politicians.
They all are part
of the family,
they play the role
and quite rightly,
they don't miss out either.
LORD CHRIS SMITH: I've always
thought that I had the great
advantage of growing up
as a teenager in the 1960s.
I came out of that period
wanting to change the world.
And I decided that democracy
was the way to achieve change.
I wanted to come to Cambridge,
so I applied.
I was absolutely terrified.
I did a terrible interview,
but remarkably, Pembroke
College gave me a place.
Spending a really wonderful
period of time here,
burying myself
in English literature
was not just a treat,
but it was a rather
wonderful preparation for life.
One of the things
that inspired me
in Cambridge was a supervision
with one of the Fellows.
We had written essays, they
weren't terribly good essays.
He said, "Let me tell you
what Wordsworth and Coleridge
were really all about."
And for the next 2 hours,
he paced up and down,
pulled books out
of the bookcase
and read quotations at us.
He conjured up
a whole world for us.
And that is the power
of a good supervision.
It can inspire,
it can fire your imagination,
it can fire your passion.
That transference
of enthusiasm and inspiration
is what Cambridge teaching,
at its very best,
is all about.
It's no accident
that Cambridge has produced
over 100 Nobel Prize winners
because of the quality
of intellectual attainment,
the depth of research,
the quality of teaching.
If we lost that,
we would be diminished terribly.
The ability to offer
to the very best and brightest
of our students,
here in Britain,
an opportunity
to flourish and to shine.
IAN MACKELLAN: I was
at Cambridge on a scholarship,
so I didn't get
there through privilege.
But once you're there,
you realise that you're
part of a great deal
of historical privilege.
If I hadn't been to Cambridge,
perhaps I wouldn't have been
invited to go to the Royal
Shakespeare Company
by these Cambridge people
who were running it.
I went for the interview
and I didn't get in.
And I think they saw
that I wasn't properly posh.
That's why.
And I was just talking a lot.
And I think they were like,
"Oh, please."
I'm not bitter, though.
I'm definitely not bitter
about it,
I never think about it,
even though it's 20 years ago.
My experience of Cambridge
was that I flourished
because I went there to work.
I loved it.
It was very high pressure.
Now, a lot of students
couldn't take the pressure,
wouldn't enjoy the pressure,
would hate the pressure.
I'm Callum Sullivan
and I recently graduated
with a degree in music.
I captained my Cambridge crew
in the Boat Race
against Oxford to victory.
When I really decided
I wanted to apply to Cambridge
and put in the work
that meant I could
get there was actually
probably watching a Boat Race.
I realised at that point
that this was an event
that was really special
and that I actually
had the capacity
to possibly
be in this environment.
Best decision I ever made.
Once you're part of
this Boat Club, you have to be,
particularly for the six seven
months leading up to the race,
totally locked in and making
sure that you're getting
as much out
of yourself as you can.
And we're all expected to do
really well in our studies
as well, so it
is a bit of a challenge
and one that's really,
really great learning.
We usually end the week
on a pretty tough session
on Sundays, earn the day
off we tend to say.
Get up a little bit later
than usual on Monday mornings,
head to Nanna Mex for a Monday
burrito on the student deal.
You know, when you're sitting
on the start line on race day
and you know that there's
something like 6 million
people watching on BBC One
and you know
that there's 200,000 people
on the banks of the Thames.
And you're sitting there
and you're absolutely trying
to do anything but make
a mess of the first stroke
and end up losing
your crew the race.
And that's basically all you
can think about, otherwise,
you do exactly that.
To hear the roars
of the crowds coming through
Hammersmith Bridge,
it's a really special
thing to be a part of.
So my first plaque
is yet to go up,
it's somewhere in one
of the corners of the room.
Oh, there it is.
Yes, that's my plaque there
and I'm right in the middle
of the 5-seater.
And I think it's destined
for one of these spaces
on the walls up here.
This race has been part
of national culture
a little bit for so long.
I thoroughly
enjoy the Oxbridge Boat Race.
My number two sister went
to Cambridge and Geordie went
to Oxford and my number five
sister went to Oxford as well.
So there is
this extraordinary rivalry,
light blue and dark blue
and obviously as children
we were always
very excited if somebody sank,
we were usually
waiting for that.
IAN MACKELLAN: It was the first
thing I ever saw on television.
I was walking past a shop front
and there was a crowd
looking into the window
and I went to join them
and on a little screen
about that size,
there was some brown,
shady image.
And I realised it was moving
image, which was happening
at that moment and so that was
the first time I saw television.
Oh, well,
I've always wanted Cambridge
to win the Boat Race,
because my uncle
went to Cambridge.
It's not really a race, is it?
Because it's the same two
competing for something
that's largely
irrelevant to everybody else.
[cheerful keyboard instrumental]
Cricket originated in England,
originated in the countryside.
I can't possibly imagine
what it was like back then,
but look at where
we've come to now, so.
Cricket I think is part
of tradition and of course
Lord's Cricket Ground
is as much about the ceremony
as I guess the game itself.
You've got Lord's Cricket
Ground, regarded as the home
of cricket and it's still
only colonial countries
who predominantly play cricket,
which says
everything about the game.
Cricket is essentially,
a quintessentially
English pastime.
There are very few games where
you can play for five days,
go home, do anything
you like in between,
and at the end of five days,
have a draw
and everyone be relatively
happy with that result.
I was brought up
on cricket because at the end
of our garden
in Wigan was the local
cricket club and I watched
their ground
through the seasons.
In the winter when
it was fallow and snowing,
and then in the spring
when the grass
could be cut and the players
arrived to practice.
And then at the weekends
when they actually played games,
I could watch them.
And I became
not a player of cricket,
but I was
in the score box marking
the rather
complicated way in which
points are scored in cricket.
You go to a cricket match
and you don't have
to watch it all the time.
There's plenty of time
to have a chat with the person
next door to you,
often about cricket.
"Oh, they're starting again."
To think of it as a game
in which people win or lose,
no, it's a different
sort of game altogether,
it's the game of life.
KARL DUNN: Okay, in my house,
there was no cricket,
there was no rugby,
there was no Aussie Rules,
none of that stuff.
We all sailed.
I don't know anything
about team sports.
Nothing. You're truly
asking the wrong Australian.
I can't believe they didn't
take away my passport.
But yes, I don't know
anything about cricket.
Sorry.
Her Majesty the Queen
and the Duke of Edinburgh
many times
attended test matches,
often meeting the players
on the field of play
during the tea interval.
Only on one occasion
has the Queen actually stayed
for lunch, however.
That was during a test
match against Australia.
Her favourite tipple,
Dubonnet, was not present.
So a member of the kitchen
staff had to be dispatched
to find an off licence somewhere
in St John's Wood
or Maida Vale,
which had a bottle
of Dubonnet in stock.
And then had to dash back
to the ground in time
to serve the Queen her favourite
aperitif before lunch.
Just one of the little,
extra measures that we take
to ensure our special guests
are well looked after
at this ground.
EMMA ELWICK-BATES: I lived
in Bloomsbury for several years
in London and it's an area
that's very special to me.
And I think what
I love about it,
other than
the Dickensian heritage,
is all
the little twists and turns
and you stumble
upon these small museums
that you may
not have known existed.
I particularly love
the Sir John Soane's Museum.
And is quite famously
said that the British
are such avid collectors.
And there's no better example
of a random, delightful,
at times horrifying, collection
of antiquities hidden away
on a quiet street in Bloomsbury.
DR. BRUCE BOUCHER:
People look at these buildings,
they look at a place
like this and they see
something that's
really like a fly in amber.
We're in the library dining room
of Sir John Soane's townhouse.
Which became,
after his death, his museum.
He was appointed
to be the architect of the Bank
of England and that was probably
his greatest achievement,
and he was awarded a knighthood.
He was also fortunate
in marrying an heiress,
Eliza Smith.
One of the great tragedies
was that only two years
after they moved into the house,
Eliza Soane died.
Soane was disconsolate.
The tomb he designed
a few months
after her death
and it was
a remarkable departure
from contemporary tombs.
Giles Gilbert Scott
must have looked at it
and being intimate
with the house
and the collections,
it would have
come to him as an Edicule,
which offers shelter
for communication.
Gilbert Scott,
who designed the phone box,
he saw this
and thought that shape,
and I hope he thought
and that love story,
will be just perfect
for this new invention
called the phone.
His inspiration
was a brilliant bit
of lateral thinking,
if you like.
Gilbert Scott
wanted it to be silver,
but the Post Office said,
"Oh no, budget, budget"
and they said it's going
to have to be red.
And now that's an iconic sense
of Englishness in this country
and right around the world.
[soft piano music]
So we're here today
at Henry Poole.
At this stage,
we've done now the pattern.
We've gone through
the detailing with yourself.
Back width is good,
shoulder width is good.
At this point, I'd be asking
you if there's anything you
don't like, anything you want
to change,
you know, button heights.
Sleeve length,
they're just a little bit short.
So I'm just going to put
in a quarter of an inch
on those and
then you should show about
a centimetre 3/8 of shirt cuff.
Sure.
I mean, I really
like how comfortable it feels
and how light
and also I like the color.
Obviously, it's a little bit
livelier than a plain navy,
but without
being overly flashy, you know,
if you had a real
electric blue suit,
then, you know,
how many times are
you going to wear it
before you get bored
or people say, "Here he comes in
his electric blue suit again?"
We have to admire
the entrepreneurial spirit
of the original John Lobb,
who in 1863 saw the Prince
of Wales in the park and saw
that he left a muddy footprint
and then he used that
as an imprint to make his first
riding boots, which he'd
gifted to the Prince of Wales
before he was King.
That's how the long
standing relationship
with this heritage brand,
the Royal Family and of course,
the Royal Warrant
that John Lobb has carried
for so long, came about.
[hammering]
JONATHAN LOBB:
My great-great-grandfather
founded the firm.
The fact that
it's a family run business.
Behind that family run
element of it
is the fact that
it's an independent business
and I think it is
that element of independence,
which is maybe a
quintessentially English trait.
In World War II,
when my great-uncle had started
running the firm, there
was a moment when the bombs
were falling on London.
One evening he decided
that it would be best to have
the lasts move out into
the country to keep them safe.
Early the next day,
the building was bombed
and it was condemned.
The lasts are very much
the lifeblood of the firm.
Keeping those from
being burned was a good move.
So those are all old names.
Thing is, we've actually
got to the point where lots
of people don't know
who these people are anymore.
-Yes.
-David Niven, Lord Olivier.
This is Peter O'Toole,
Aristotle Onassis.
Sinatra.
-FRANK MANNION: Wow.
-JONATHAN: Small feet.
Those are well used.
We had a lot of work
for him over the years.
FRANK MANNION: Jackie Onassis,
she had large feet,
I have to say.
Yes, she was quite tall
I think, she was a tall lady.
FRANK MANNION: Yes.
Some people,
I have heard, will be asked
to be buried in their shoes.
Obviously, their favourite
items that they may have had
during their lives.
Well, they do say
you should judge a man by shoes.
Regardless of what
he might be wearing.
This is what we're faced with,
which is this blue suit
which you're having made.
-FRANK MANNION: Yes.
-By Simon.
You might prefer something
which is a little bit more,
sort of
in keeping with the suit.
The one I think that really
sort of complemented
what you were wearing
was the double-monk shoe,
it's designed as quite a sort
of comfortable shoe as well.
Which is good for everyday wear.
[thoughtful piano instrumental]
IAN MACKELLAN: British
weather is, for me, perfect.
It changes every day.
You never get bored.
It's reliable
in its unreliability.
FRED MICHELL: The best cab
service in the world
is the London taxi driver,
right or wrong?
SIMON JOHNS: Definitely, Fred.
Just our origin, it's being
going so long, it's an icon.
It's like a red bus
or a telephone box.
Come to London,
you ride in a black cab.
FRANK MANNION: If I got into
the back of your cab and said,
"Take me to the umbrella shop."
DRIVERS: We'd take you
to James Smith & Sons,
New Oxford St, Bloomsbury.
Of course we know it.
SIMON: Yes.
I suppose rain
is quintessentially English,
hence the umbrella has to also
be quintessentially English
to protect you
from this ghastly weather.
Having said that,
today we are blessed
with some beautiful blue skies.
OZ CLARKE: I love it
when I see those sort of shops
which do something
very particular.
Which are charming,
which say something about us
and which I would
hate to die out.
That emporium of umbrellas.
It's a mad idea
and I'm absolutely delighted
it's still there.
PHIL NAISMITH: James Smith
and Sons have been in business
since 1830 and we're
on to the sixth generation.
It's quintessential English,
but it's actually
a little bit more than that.
The umbrella was said
to have started either in Egypt
or China, and the real
pick up with it came
with the invention
of steel as part
of the Industrial Revolution.
People had more money,
more time to spend on things.
Slowly then, umbrellas
became popular in London
as a fashion accessory.
A good umbrella
becomes part of you.
It can make you stand up tall,
but it can also make
you feel good inside as well.
We've always been
taught you must never open
your umbrella indoors,
you always have
to store it wrapped up.
Part of the folklore, we say,
is where that came from
is that the salesmen would tell
people that it was bad luck
to leave an umbrella
open indoors.
So then they'd be
folded up, they'd be wet
and because
they were made of silk
in those days,
then they would rot
and then they'd come
back to buy another umbrella.
You go to James Smith now,
they've got an enormous
horseshoe saying,
"Don't worry, it's not bad luck.
You can do what you
like with your umbrella.
This horseshoe will
protect you." Honestly.
There's a secret part
in every Englishman which wants
to be The Gentleman Spy.
The immaculately
tailored Savile Row suit,
the rolled up umbrella.
It's as deeply rooted
in English culture
these days, as cricket is.
If you've got the money and
if you've got the inclination
to have someone look after you,
to treat you, to pamper you,
go to somewhere like Trumper's.
They may even give you the
cologne that James Bond wore.
We're at Geo. F. Trumper.
It's a flagship store,
this has been here 100 years.
Open the door
in the morning and your body
gets the goose bumps going.
PAULETTE TRUMPER:
We always give accessories
to the James Bond films.
You could miss it if
you didn't know what you were
looking at in the bathroom,
but we usually spot them.
People trust us.
All the famous
people that come to us
trust that we'll
never mention who they are.
We never phone magazines
or newspapers when they arrive.
They come in,
feel very relaxed,
as if nobody's recognized them.
FRANK MANNION: Ian McKellen?
Yes.
Oh, I have been there once.
Yes, to get a shave.
Yes, it was very good.
PAULETTE TRUMPER: So even
the current Prime Minister
was a customer of
our other branch in St James'.
We actually
don't do his hair anymore,
which is probably
noticeable by the haircuts.
What, he pays
to get that haircut?
I just assumed his mum did it.
That's ridiculous.
[birds tweeting]
I love looking at gardens,
sitting in gardens,
walking through gardens.
I am hopeless
at being a gardener.
JAMIE HARRIS: Sir Edmund Loder
that classic example
of an English eccentric,
having that sort
of passion that drive
to build a garden
on such a grand scale,
a great deal of it
by his own hand.
Leonardslee's
often referred to as one
of the most important
woodland gardens in England.
A lot of the English
garden design was taking
influence from Europe.
After the English landscape
movement and the woodland
garden explosion,
suddenly English gardens
were influencing Europe.
And apparently Hitler
had his eye on Leonardslee
as his new home.
The great English film
Black Narcissus was shot here.
Sir Edmund created
a landscape which could pass
for the Himalayas, certainly
with the rhododendrons and
azaleas.
It's a place to get lost in,
a place to wander
and every day
it's a privilege and an honor
to come in and work
in this classic example
of an English woodland garden.
PROFESSOR MICHAEL WHEELER:
One of the definitions
of Britishness
is a love of gardens.
So even if you're living on
the fifth floor of a high rise
and if you have
a little balcony outside,
it's full of pots
with things growing in it.
It's extraordinary.
The British love gardening.
The English are obsessed
with gardens and that probably
culminates with the Chelsea
Flower Show every year.
NICOLA HALE: It brings
a real mix of different types
of design
in one location for people
to just get inspiration
from for their own gardens
and for
their own houses even as well.
This is essentially like,
I suppose, the Champions League
of gardening that
I'm visiting today, I think,
and having
had a little walk around,
I'm definitely
getting that sense.
This is fantastic, I mean it's
if you like, in our back garden.
FRANK MANNION: Chelsea is the
quintessential British occasion.
It is. One of them.
FRANK MANNION: What is
so quintessentially British
about the Chelsea Flower Show?
That we're here
in this weather with no coats
and with nothing else on.
SOF MCVEIGH:
And it's fun, and it's fun.
You get the chance
to put a pretty frock on
and you see beautiful things
and chat to lovely people.
And we are a Royal Borough,
because Queen Victoria,
on her deathbed,
decreed that the borough
she was born in should
become a Royal Borough.
So that's why we're the Royal
Borough of Kensington & Chelsea.
And later on this afternoon,
we'll be welcoming
some of the Royal Family,
some of the people
that live in our boroughs.
So it all comes together
on our RHS Chelsea Flower Show.
♪♪♪
It's truly brilliant
just to meet a fellow queen.
Especially today, where
it is the art form of gardening
at the Chelsea Flower Show.
And the art form of drag.
And just a gorgeous
British icon, as well.
WOMAN: Absolutely.
Here here.
What a pleasure
it is to meet Judi Dench.
Thank you.
Is it really bad as well
that I really just wanted
to joke and be like,
"It's such a pleasure
to meet Maggie Smith."
But no, it truly is a pleasure
to meet you, honestly.
And you, you look beautiful.
Thank you.
I was making handbags
in the early seventies
and the opportunity
came to buy Launer.
When I bought the company,
it had the Royal Warrant,
but it'd not been really used.
I obviously wanted
to go direct to the palace
and slowly managed to do that.
Oh, the Queen
is a delightful person.
Just like the lady next door.
Very interested in what we do,
because when she was
in the factory, she spent
a good afternoon with us.
EMMA ELWICK-BATES: It's reported
that the Queen has 200 handbags,
predominantly
Launer London handbags.
If I was lucky enough
to be invited for an audience
with the Queen, I think
the most mortifying thing for me
would be if she moved
her Launer handbag
from her left to her right arm.
It is suggested that's her
indication to the courtiers
to come and rescue her.
The Launer handbag, as well
as being a stylish accessory,
has become her escape route
in difficult social situations.
It's an understated
British way of getting out
of an awkward situation.
We're very lucky
to be in The Crown.
The costume designers
were interested in coming
to the showroom, because
they knew that Mrs. Thatcher
and Her Majesty
carried my handbags.
That's very intriguing
that two silhouetted,
famous, pair of ladies
chose the same handbag brand.
This was the Traviata,
which is the Queen's.
I know this
is a beautiful white one.
Mrs. Thatcher had the Olympia,
which was the nearest
to the bag that she carried
when she bought from me.
Both great ladies.
[string instrumental]
LOUIS BARNES: James Purdey
& Sons have been making guns
for quite a long time now.
They are probably the finest
gunmaker in the world,
as British gunmakers are.
These take around about
two and a half, three years
to build, so
this is a real work of art.
New this would be 100,000 plus.
You will see
someone using one of these,
particularly
on a day like today,
which is the
Glorious Twelfth.
It's probably the most
exhilarating sport of all,
bird shooting, I think.
They can beat on the wing
at up to 70 miles an hour,
which is a real sport.
Hitting them is quite a feat.
The Royals are traditionally
very involved in country sports,
particularly shooting.
They're quite well known
to be part of that scene.
That quintessential
British scene, yes.
IAN MACKELLAN: I think
I was brought up to think
it was cruel to kill animals.
And the idea
of the posh folks going off
and the centre
of their activity,
being killing something.
I think you've got
to be of a certain frame
of mind of which I am not.
I'd much rather
they were gathered together,
the central
point of the weekend
was when they all dressed up and
did charades, played charades,
put on a little pantomime.
Shooting a bird...
Aww.
If that's essentially English,
it's not an Englishness
that I can respond to at all.
I look at the Glorious Twelfth
and think it is a load
of baloney
as far as I'm concerned.
I'm quite grateful
that they're not
blapping away
at the grouse all year long,
but it's a quite absurd
piece of gastronomic elitism.
I don't know anybody who eats
grouse on August the 12th,
but I'm sure if we went to some
of the smart hotels in London,
they would serve it to me for
an astronomical amount of money,
which I do not wish to pay.
We're at the Stafford Hotel,
and today we're
in the Game Bird, which is our
wonderful signature restaurant.
This hotel
has been here since 1912,
but Glorious Twelfth
goes back to 1853.
So ever since that day,
we've been serving grouse
on the 12th of August
and get excited by it.
It was shot this morning
and is on its way
from the North Yorkshire Moors.
It's the Glorious Twelfth,
first grouse of the season.
We have it here at The Stafford.
STUART PROCTER:
It's a very discreet place.
So we're not about celebrity,
we're not about royalty,
but they all come here.
Her Majesty,
the Queen visits the Stafford.
The Queen Mother used to visit
for afternoon tea weekly
walking up from Clarence House.
The cellars served the King
of England when he lived
in St. James's Palace.
We served the port to the king.
It is a very special place.
SIMON CUNDEY: We're going
to be getting through
what's called the blessing.
The blessing involves
the final fitting.
We're looking at the small
details now and the general
comfort that we hear from you
and how you enjoy the suit.
Also, we have the extra cloth
there, which I must say Frank,
if any prosperity takes place,
we can have four inches
of extra cloth inside to allow
that difference in inches.
So do not haste,
we are there for you.
This is good to go now.
[string instrumental]
PROFESSOR MICHAEL WHEELER:
Of course, in reality,
I couldn't show you around
because it's members only.
FRANK MANNION: Absolutely.
We're rule breakers.
So let me just
show you some things here
in the South Library
that are quite interesting.
This is Faraday's wheelchair.
Faraday, our great scientist,
was also the honorary secretary
just at the very beginning
of the club's history.
And there
we have Dickens' chair.
And this incredibly
tall arrangement,
with the three tiers,
was the cheapest way
of accommodating this huge
number of books in one room.
The only problem is that a lot
of older members who have
vertigo are terrified
of going up there,
so we send the library staff up
to find the books.
I can well imagine that.
[chuckling]
PROFESSOR MICHEAL WHEELER:
The Athenaeum does have
an amazing role of honor.
Charles Dickens,
Charles Darwin, Churchill,
J.M.W. Turner, who does
those wonderful interiors,
member of the club.
Wherever you look in a way.
BRIAN WALDY: The clubs
went through a very hard time
in Pall Mall and in St James'.
And they were out of favor,
they were old fashioned,
they were seen to be a relic
of the 19th century.
If you read the novels
of Dickens and Thackeray,
there always seemed to be
somebody going off to the club
and somebody coming
back from Parliament to report
over a nice glass of Port.
NEVILLE JAMES: I've been a
member of a private members club
purely and simply because
I've got it as
part of a promotion
and part of my work
and what I was doing.
But average person, private
member's club, is irrelevant.
That's out of our league.
-Yeah.
-That's out of our league.
We are just London boys.
That's another...
It's another world for us.
Another world, exactly, yeah.
But they're lovely places.
-Apparently.
-Yeah.
We only go to the main door,
we don't get invited in,
we just drop off.
It's a very
useful way of making sure
that you can meet someone
and entertain them
in the middle of London,
but I would say it's more
a functional thing for me
than part
of my being and identity.
IAN MCKELLEN: The only
real advantage of a club
would be that it'd be a place
where you could
go and sit quietly.
But who might come up to you
and want to
have a good long chat?
Actors have a number of clubs
that they could
be expected to join.
The Garrick, but women
aren't allowed to be members
of the Garrick Club.
Why would I want to go to a club
that wouldn't have women in it?
I don't know.
The men's clubs,
they can go there,
they can sit,
they can talk about racing
and Backgammon and things
and I don't
necessarily want to do that.
You also know where they are.
That's probably quite positive.
You shouldn't
regard them as exclusive,
just an opportunity
to meet other people
and to widen your
own circle of friends
and the bonhomie and the banter
that can arise from it.
It's fun.
It's quite British.
PROFESSOR MICHAEL WHEELER:
John Wilson Croker,
he saw that in London, there
were lots of political clubs,
there were lots of what
were known as fashionable clubs,
really, for the aristocracy,
if you like.
But what was needed
perhaps was a club for writers
and artists and scientists,
which would not
be about politics
and would not be about class.
The club built
this Grecian temple
and under the auspices of Athena
and that sense
of classical wisdom,
the scientists, artists,
writers, judges,
cabinet ministers,
bishops, whatever their views,
they could get along together.
A place at
the Athenaeum was like gold.
This is a very
British institution,
which suits me very well.
It reflects aspects of Britain
and its history that I warm to.
You know, inclusiveness,
liberalism and conservatism.
And one of the things you have
to be very careful about here,
at club table when you
don't know whose opposite you,
is you might be
sounding off about some subject
and you find
the person opposite you,
is the world's
leading expert in it.
So you tend to find people
around here are quite cautious
to check on who's present.
That's happened to me.
Terrifying.
In terms
of the membership of this club,
what I've tracked
is the story of Britain,
because Britain has
become much more dominated
by the middle class
than by the upper class.
You're aware of classes.
You know Shaw said, "When an
Englishman opens his mouth..."
[laughs]
"...people judge him."
The Americans are
quite good at class, actually.
Particularly among
the upper echelons.
But the British have
been very class-conscious
and some still are.
But I think there's
been a big change there.
I think there's
Has the class system
changed so sufficiently
that we're able to move forward?
It probably has, because
probably there's more people
from various backgrounds
making vast amounts of money.
I suppose that's
the new class system
now in our country, isn't it?
People who have money.
People don't have money.
Neil.
How are you?
NEIL MCLAREN:
Frank, nice to see you again.
Nice to see you too, absolutely.
Okay Frank, so here we are,
all ready for
your second fitting.
You'll see a slight difference
to when you were
last here in so much
as we've now made
the bespoke shoe trees.
Which my younger brother
made in our tree making section.
He's a fairly new--
new character.
He's only been here
30 years or so, so yes,
we're still trying to train him.
NEIL MCLAREN:
He's a lifer, he's a lifer.
For sure, but most of us are,
most of us are so, yes.
So the trees are also bespoke
and we're left with this
beautifully varnished shoe tree,
which is an exact
replica of your foot also.
So, it's got the correct width
and contours that your foot has,
so the shoe will
never shrink back,
you'd always
maintain that size and shape,
which is very important
for the longevity of the shoe.
JONATHAN LOBB:
The double monk is a shoe
that's been part
of the firm's history
since it was
created by my grandfather.
It has a sort
of timeless quality to it.
NEIL MCLAREN: So you've got
the oak bark sole hammered
and shaped to your last
and hand-stitched onto the weld.
The heel was built up with--
There's no block heel, this
is individual layers of leather.
Every pair of shoes goes through
four different
craftsman's hands.
We've got the closer who
makes the beautiful uppers,
the shoemaker who's
stitched all the sole
and the heel together.
And then the tree makers
who make the wooden inserts
to go in afterwards.
So all these guys are
highly trained, highly skilled.
It's very much
a team collective effort.
I get to see you
and get all praise
what a beautiful shoe it is,
so I get
the glory when they fit well,
but by the same token,
I also get
the grief if they don't.
So I guess it's
a double-edged sword.
FRANK MANNION:
I kind of feel like
I'd want to sleep
in them if I could.
[laughing]
If you're invited to one of our
many amazing country houses
for the weekend,
you wouldn't go wrong
by wearing a Henry Poole suit
and a John Lobb
shoe for your arrival.
I'm sure you
recognize this room.
Oh wow. I do, the library.
Well, there are
many portraits in it.
There's one there
of the 1st Earl of Carnarvon.
Obviously, Geordie
and I have got to number eight.
What's quite special
about Highclere,
is there has been
an estate here, a home here,
if you like,
for at least 1200 years.
So one of the most special
things about this building,
heritage, gardens,
home is the longevity.
I think the idea that
you have this great perspective
looking backwards,
a sense of an anchor,
perhaps a sense of reassurance
in quite a changeable world.
We've been here a while.
In 1922, Lord Carnarvon
and Highclere Castle
were front page news
around the world.
Against all the odds, Lord
Carnarvon and Howard Carter,
two maverick Englishmen,
discovered the steps,
the 22 steps which led
down to the Tomb of Tutankhamun.
That glint of gold.
That glimpse back into a
Pharaonic world 3500 years old,
captured the whole
world's imagination.
What a story to have
at Highclere Castle.
My father-in-law had
always told me the story,
the end of World War II,
he and some of his Army friends
with Princess Elizabeth
and Princess Margaret ran around
the streets
of London and did the conga
and just celebrated
the end of World War II.
And they were all
standing outside the black gates
of Buckingham Palace.
My father-in-law
with Princess Elizabeth
and Margaret shouting
up to the King and Queen,
"Long live the King and Queen."
They'd always remained friends
and she had a love of racing,
so he was her racing manager,
but her racing friend above all.
Geordie, my husband,
and I took over the Castle
after his father had sadly died.
His parents had
never lived in it.
It reminds you that a home
is about welcoming
friends to the door.
Julian and Emma Fellowes
were good friends
and I thought it'd be fun
and I love putting
together weekend house parties,
it was where this house started
in Victorian times.
So Julian Fellowes
said that he wrote Downton
with Highclere in mind.
None of us dreamt or
guessed how successful
Downton Abbey would be,
how we'd all fall in love
with the different characters,
whether it's Bates
or Anne or Lady Mary.
It's really Julian Fellowes'
excellent writing
and I guess the way Maggie Smith
delivers all her lines
so perfectly.
It's just making people happy.
That's all Highclere
wants to do.
Hats have almost disappeared.
Ties have almost disappeared.
Well, we'll be
naked next I should think.
Lock's dates back to 1676.
We're the oldest hat shop
in the world
and one of the oldest
still family-owned businesses
in the world as well.
We originally opened on
the other side of the street.
This is the sunny
side of the street.
You always do more business
on the sunny side of the street,
because that's
where people want to walk.
My great, great, great,
however many
great-grandfathers it is,
was a gentleman
called James Benning
and he is famous as he is
the original Mad Hatter
that Lewis Carroll
based the character on
in Alice in Wonderland.
So I am a direct descendant
of the original Mad Hatter.
I'm very proud of that.
We've got a great connection
with James Bond.
We hatted
Sean Connery in the '60s.
In Dr. No,
he famously wore a Trilby.
In Goldfinger, Oddjob wore a,
what we call
a square crown Coke
and that was the one
with the reinforced brim,
which he used to throw
at his victims
and sliced their heads off
and all sorts.
Famously, the square
crown Coke was also worn
by Winston Churchill.
We were very proud
that Winston Churchill
was a big customer of ours,
before and during
and after the war.
When the war was
taking a turn for the worse,
you'd find that
when you look in the ledgers,
there'd be an insertion for
Winston Churchill for a new hat,
because it was a way
of him lifting his spirits
when the chips were down.
One of the moments in history
that my family
are very proud of,
is that my grandfather
fitted the crown
for the Queen's coronation.
We were commissioned by
Garrards, the Queen's jewellers.
to make a velvet pad
that went inside the crown,
so it would size it down,
so it would fit
the Queen on her coronation day.
So we use a machine
called a conformateur,
a French invention,
dates back to 1849
and we still use
the same machine today.
We haven't found
a better way of doing it.
Looks like an instrument
of torture.
I think someone described it
as quite steampunk
and I quite like that.
Right, okay, so if you
look straight ahead for me.
Plonk the old girl on,
get it centred for you
and then just pushes down.
Looks like it should hurt,
but it doesn't hurt at all.
And then we just
give that a squeeze.
There we go, lift that off.
It's little bit of an old girl,
so we have to give it a little
bit of gentle persuasion.
And then hopefully, there's
an imprint of your head shape.
There you go, sir.
That is amazing
and it's an exotic looking egg.
Yes, yes.
What I love is when
I get a customer coming in here,
a young guy comes in and says,
"I've always wanted a Lock hat
"because my grandfather
wore one."
[inspiring orchestral
instrumental]
♪♪♪
WILLIAM SKINNER:
Frank, you've been very patient
for the various visits to here
and today's visit is to
see the outfit completed now.
I am very, very pleased
as how it's turned out.
[horse loudly neighs]
LORD PALMER: My son
being a racehorse trainer...
I mean, he's had as many
as over 100 horses in training
at any one time
and quite how he manages
to know which horse
to run, in which race,
in which country, I don't know.
And of course,
a lot of staff here follow Hugo.
Quite often. I'm stopped
in the passage and they go,
"Hello, my Lord,
I'm 100 pounds better off
than when I last saw you."
COMMENTATOR: ...won by
the favourite, Chauncery House!
Trained by Nicky Henderson.
Ridden by Nico De Boinville.
We're here at Sandown Park,
a quintessential
British racecourse.
ALEX TRUESDALE: We try
and come as much as we can,
we absolutely love horses.
We have a share in
a couple of horses as well,
so it's our favourite place
to be.
Yeah.
Sandown Park has always
been a favourite racecourse
of the Royal Family.
Indeed, the Queen Mother
used to say
it was her favourite racecourse.
And Nicky Henderson,
who trains for the Queen,
is here today.
I know people don't
like two-horse races.
I love them,
in fact, one-horse races.
[laughing]
NICKY HENDERSON:
Concorde used to come over
5 to 11 every morning.
You could set your clock by it.
Right, we're going again.
I'm Nicky Henderson,
a racehorse trainer.
I was always equestrian-minded,
if you like.
Even from school days
and at Eton in those days,
racing was about
the biggest crime.
To be caught on a racecourse
was a heinous crime.
Well, I was very lucky actually,
because the Queen Mother's
horses came here
and we had some wonderful times.
I mean, she was
a spectacular lady.
I think she
really enjoyed the people
that were involved in racing.
Racing's full of characters.
Some good, some bad,
mostly good.
The Queen took over
the Queen Mother's horses
and all the mares
that were breeding.
She toured the horses
and she loved to come down
and see them.
And it's lovely that she
takes such an interest in it all
and as you know,
racing is probably her number
one relaxation, hobby, passion.
Both the Queen Mother
and the Queen, they're A,
very knowledgeable, but B,
terribly easy to work with
and talk to about something
that we both love.
The Gold Cup, the Champion
Hurdle, the Champion Chase,
they are the pinnacle,
the Oscar, if you like,
of the racing world.
Over the years,
there've been some good days
and I suppose these
are the special ones,
because these are Bobs Worth
and Long Run's Gold Cups.
2012 was a particularly
good Cheltenham festival.
Horse's feet vary in size
quite considerably
and as you can see,
there are big ones
and there are little ones.
This is actually a youngster
of Her Majesty's,
called Rapid Flight.
He's-- They're all homebred.
And he's a rather sweet horse.
He won the other day and he's
due to run again this weekend,
if he doesn't eat the door.
But he's just a nice youngster,
his life's in front of him,
so who knows?
And what is
the breakfast of champions?
Well, this morning he-- What?
-What he's actually had to eat?
-Yes.
He's had a bowl of nuts,
he's had some hay,
he's been out,
he's been actually
jumping this morning.
Wow, so beautiful.
So, Rapid Flight.
He's called Rapid Flight.
I don't know how rapid he is,
but he won the other day
and I hope you
win again this weekend.
FRANK MANNION:
Have you ever been to the Proms?
I haven't, no.
[laughing]
I'm not very British, am I?
[light orchestral music]
♪♪♪
Could I tempt you
with a programme, sir?
Oh my goodness me,
yes of course.
Yes, it's £5 and it goes
to support our charities
and we've just surpassed
a million pounds
raised for charity.
I'm Susie Gregson,
founder and Chief Executive
of Proms at St Jude's.
FRANK MANNION:
I think you're missing
three very important letters
there, Susie.
MBE. I was awarded an MBE
by Her Majesty, the Queen.
I was awarded it
for services to the community.
Pretty much for founding
Proms at St Jude's
and for keeping it
going for so many years.
♪♪♪
Proms was set up
almost 30 years ago.
I don't think
any of us anticipated
that it would last
as long as it did
and be as much loved as it is.
By pulling together,
we've become a community
and over the years,
we've consistently
raised money for good causes.
It's almost entirely
run by volunteers of all ages.
Proms isn't a new concept.
It started, I think,
in the mid-18th century
and it started
with pleasure gardens,
where people could stroll around
while musicians played.
Well, tonight we've got
a wonderful concert
with Braimah
and Konya Kanneh-Mason.
The Kanneh-Masons will
be playing Elgar's Sospiri
and Elgar, of course,
was actually living in
Hampstead when he wrote it.
So really, we're playing it
on his doorstep.
♪♪♪
BRAIMAH KANNEH-MASON:
It was special to play a piece
in Hampstead knowing
that it was written so close
to where we were performing.
We both live in West Hampstead.
It was a really lovely
atmosphere for us to play in.
If Elgar was sat
in the audience,
I would love
to speak to him afterwards
and ask how he thinks we did
and what he thinks
we should do or change.
I grew up with music
around the house.
It was always there,
so I think that's how I
naturally gravitated towards it,
because then I was
just immersed in music
from a very early age.
BRAIMAH KANNEH-MASON:
We were extremely lucky
to have parents
who grew up loving music.
They really believed
that it was an essential part
of the education, and we've
just been really, really lucky
to have had
incredible opportunities
and an amazing support network.
[mournful violin and piano duet]
♪♪♪
DYLAN KAWENDE:
My name is Dylan Kawende.
I'm the British-born son
of Congolese Rwandan refugees.
I set up
the #GetDyl2Cambridge campaign
to pursue my dream
of becoming a lawyer.
So my dad received an offer to
study at Cambridge University,
but he couldn't
take up the place
because he didn't
have the funding.
Back in the '90s,
my parents migrated to the UK
during a time
of chaos and disorder.
They always dreamed
of a better future for myself
and my four siblings.
So when they came over here,
the aspiration was that
we would all benefit society.
And that has helped me
to forge my own path
and despite
the financial hurdles
of studying law at
Cambridge University,
I've been able
to pursue my dream.
Lots of people will
recognise my campaign,
my #GetDyl2Cambridge campaign.
An arduous effort,
but definitely worth it
and I wouldn't have
had all these resources
if not for
the people who believed in me.
It's been an amazing journey,
an amazing experience.
There is still that
feeling in rural England.
There's something
rather lovely about it.
I love going into old churches
in little villages
and sensing the history and
the sense of peace and quiet.
I love going to Grantchester
and having cream tea
in the orchard tea rooms.
Is that the whole
of modern Britain?
No, of course not.
But it's part of the whole.
IAN MCKELLEN: Chocolate box,
Christmas card, the village.
I'm not a villager,
I'm a provincial urban lad,
so I get much more sentimental
about the paintings
of L.S. Lowry.
Lowry painted the now demolished
cityscapes of the North.
The mean little houses
and streets
and the big overpowering
factories and churches.
Smoke in the air.
Damp. Dirty.
Well, the North
was a bit like that
when I was growing up and I can
get sentimental about that,
rather than...
anything down at Grantchester
with all those posh people.
You know, the mountains
of the Lake District,
the mountains
of the Highlands of Scotland,
they are some of the oldest
landmasses in the world.
The Himalayas, the tall
mountains these days are new,
they've just arrived.
The Pennines have been
here since time immemorial
and I get sentimental
about that.
If I am trying to think
what it is to be British
is to have lived in
the variable landscapes.
Which people down South
here on this little island,
people who live in London,
they don't know about mountains.
There aren't any mountains here,
there're a few hills.
No mountains.
I don't think there's
a direct link between us
today living in London and the
London where Shakespeare lived.
I mean that's long, long ago
and it was very, very different.
Very violent,
horrible place, actually.
Cruelty on the streets.
Deaths in the air.
Short lives.
Dirty. Disease-ridden.
Mmm-mmm.
BRIAN NEWMAN-SMITH: You're
at Bekonscot Model Village,
the oldest model village
in the world.
This is where we got
the quirky names.
The fruiter is,
You Are A Peach, Heavenly Soles
and this is the smallest
Marks & Spencers in the world.
What did they sell in the '30s?
And they sent us
all the information.
And basically they just
sold hats, stockings, shoes,
gloves and scarves.
Things like that.
Not like they do today.
This is a little memorial to
our founder, Roland Callingham.
People think he's buried there,
but he's not.
FRANK MANNION: Why do you think
the 1930s was chosen
as the period?
I think it was
the time was just about right,
because then after that,
everything sort of changed.
I think we got it just right.
FRANK MANNION: So it was
almost like an idyllic,
quintessentially British time?
Oh, I think so.
No doubt about that. Yes.
Yes, it was. It was.
That is English.
Even now you go out and about
on a Saturday and Sunday,
they're playing cricket.
One thing we can't
get to scale are the fish.
These are enormous,
mutant whales in scale, so yes.
[toy train clicking]
FRANK MANNION: Do you think
the trains run on time here?
Oh, definitely.
No leaves on the line
or anything like that, no.
Hiya.
FRANK MANNION: Why are
Pixar movies so successful?
Because Pixar works for kids
and it works for adults.
Maybe that's the secret
success formula for Bekonscot.
BRIAN NEWMAN-SMITH:
Yes, I think it is, yes.
You come as a child,
you bring your children,
you then bring the grandchildren
and it starts all over again.
And you've got Ascot Racecourse,
as it was in the 1930s.
One of our model makers
who got the MBE,
he went up to meet the Queen.
He actually spoke to the Queen
for it seems a lot longer
than everyone else,
because she said, "Oh,
I came such and such a year."
And he said, "Excuse me, Mom,
you came in," whatever.
And they chatted, you know.
If it'd been anyone else,
it'd been off
with his head, you know.
Her Majesty came with
Queen Mary in '34 and '39.
The Royal Family has decided
that it will define itself
through its theatrical
presentation of itself.
And a parade, a royal parade,
is something quite remarkable
and it's very British.
This is the first time
we've had an opportunity
to celebrate a Platinum Jubilee.
The first time
in all our history
that somebody should be
on the throne for 70 years.
How fantastic is that?
Without a doubt,
over the last few years,
the most extraordinary person,
not just who is British,
is of course,
Her Majesty the Queen.
What an amazing woman.
Well, she means the glue
that holds the nation together.
Because if you look back,
she's been one
of the most effective
and best monarchs
we've ever had.
The Queen means everything.
She's iconic.
She is an incredible role model.
She's been
a fantastic public servant.
The sport of kings, it has to
be renamed the sport of queens.
She's a star.
Like you know,
Queen is someone
everyone has to look up to.
Oh, I love the Queen.
We'll raise
a glass to the Queen.
Yeah, without
the Queen being here,
this country
wouldn't be what it is.
Exactly.
FRANK MANNION:
But the Royal Family,
aren't they German in origin?
We don't-- Well...
We don't look at them like that.
No. No.
They've become British,
I'm not sure whether
one would call them English.
Oh, they're English,
they're not German,
they are Anglo-Saxon.
Well, where did
the Anglo-Saxons come from?
The reason they
are very British,
is that they are very British.
They're hugely valued
for what they offer
and for what they represent.
The monarch has
to be apolitical.
But it doesn't
stop us, the world,
the papers analysing, perhaps,
some moments that seem
slightly more provocative.
Her most marked
sartorial choices,
was at the State Opening
of Parliament in 2017.
She came in steadfast
in a beautiful mid-blue suit,
matching hat with a perhaps
not too subtle
circular formation
of star-like yellow flowers,
resembling the European flag.
Part of me thinks if
she was allowed to talk,
she would be disappointed
that we were
breaking our ties with Europe,
but only she knows
and maybe her dresser.
♪♪♪
I was 20-years-old.
I remember all the people
in the street, myself included,
to see the car and the Queen.
Everybody was amazed by that.
That was an amazing day.
FRANK MANNION:
So you saw the Queen go by?
Absolutely.
FRANK MANNION:
Were there are George's crosses
on the streets then?
Oh, that's a good question.
I don't remember that.
[laughing]
As a country, we're pretty
good at friendly appropriation
of other people's property.
I mean, St. George,
I don't think St. George
was actually an Englishman.
I don't know too much about him.
I'm pretty sure he is the saint,
the personification of Britain.
So, yeah.
The Genoese in
the north of Italy,
their state flag
was the white and red flag
that we know is
the English flag.
JERMAINE JENAS:
From a footballer perspective,
you know, we look at that
flag with real pride
and as something to fight for
and as something that we
want to kind of take across
and do the best we could.
So I always had
a lot of love and pride
towards St George's Cross.
I'm very pleased to have
a conversation with you guys,
because you asked
me a good question.
Why there are very
little Italian flag here
and there is
also St George flag?
St George's flag was
adopted in Genoa immediately
after the first crusade.
The King of England
decided to ask the permission
to the Genoa Republic
to use the Genoa flag
in order to be safe
cruising in Mediterranean area.
Our so-called English flag,
we were actually
shelling out the reddies
year by year saying,
"Hello Genoa, sorry,
we owe you a bit of money
"for our national flag,
here you are, darling."
I was not able to understand
why they stopped in 1599.
Our King or Queen said,
"I think we've had enough
"of paying out for this Genoese
flag and I like the flag,
"let's keep it."
So this is really our flag.
We wrote down a letter to the
Queen, to Buckingham Palace.
We received a very good letter
back from Buckingham Palace,
I'm very proud
of that, saying, "Big thanks."
Maybe one day with all
the money coming from the flag,
we may reconstruct
the Republic of Genoa.
That could be a good idea.
Don't say here,
because this is illegal,
so I'm not going to say that.
Okay.
We need to have a conversation
about the St George flag.
We love it
and I'm sure you guys love too.
We can decide that April 23rd
we should have
a celebration all together.
People from England
and people from Genoa.
FRANK MANNION: I, before
starting this documentary,
thought that
the St George's flag
is a quintessentially
English flag,
but filming this documentary,
we discovered that
the English stole it
from the Italians,
from the Genoese.
Well, to be honest,
it doesn't really surprise me.
We're quite
a thievery nation, I suppose.
Is that so?
I'm not surprised
to learn that as a story.
What you've just told me
is all brand new information,
but very interesting
that maybe comes up
in a quiz one day I might use.
What is actually British?
Think about it,
fish and chips isn't, tea isn't.
A cup of tea,
"Cuppa cha, sir, cuppa cha."
Lovely Cockney, "Cuppa cha."
It's not
a Cockney word at all, "cha."
"Cha" is
a Mandarin Chinese word.
Tea is from China.
Yes so, I think that's something
to link the two cultures
together.
FRANK MANNION: Three times
the number of British people
have an Indian dish every week.
Wow, that's great, okay.
Which dish in Indian,
like, what do they like?
FRANK MANNION:
They say chicken tikka masala.
Wow, chicken tikka masala, nice.
That's my favourite too.
[laughing]
FRANK MANNION: Juana,
what's the national dish?
Well, we definitely at
home still have fish and chips
every Friday evening from
the local fish and chip shop.
Fish and chips.
That is the quintessential
English dish.
Thank you very much to those
Jewish immigrants from Europe,
who brought the idea
of fried fish with them.
Beef, of course,
is a French word, boeuf.
Mutton and lamb
comes from the Normans.
Oh and thank you
very much to the Vikings,
because they brought this idea
of smoking fish
and preserving fish,
so smoked salmon
and smoked haddock and kippers.
Thank you very
much to the Vikings.
Pork, not pig, pork.
Foreign word. Because the French
were better cooks.
That's the reason.
Imagine the UK without
any Caribbean influence.
Rum punch,
jerk chicken, Red Stripe,
like, a British person,
one of their favourite beers
is generally a Red Stripe,
everyone knows it.
Beer. English bitter beer,
one of the most famous
in the world.
That's not English.
500 years ago,
we didn't have any hops.
They came from the Netherlands,
from what is now
Belgium and Holland.
They had hops.
They showed us how to make beer.
Cider, cider,
English cider's lovely.
Thank you, the Normans.
Thank you,
William the Conqueror,
for bringing
all your apples over
and showing us
how to make cider.
Whiskey. Now,
that'll be British. Would it?
Why don't you ask the Irish?
Because it's probably
the Irish who invented whiskey.
Gin. Now gin, the quintessential
English drink.
No, it isn't.
We got the idea from Holland
and they got the idea
from North Africa via Italy.
Not English at all.
Where did the sausage come from?
The British sausage.
You can't get those abroad.
And there's nothing like one.
A British sausage.
Superior to any sausage
I've ever had
anywhere else in the world.
Now, is that not
quintessentially British?
♪♪♪
BRIAN WALDY: Who are really
English is very hard to say,
really, if you
look at the history.
The more you look back,
the more interesting it gets
and the more different peoples
come into the equation.
It's so fascinating to
see one wave of immigrants
after another so--
And it's still
continuing of course.
We've had to face our, you know,
all our phobias, haven't we?
Our racisms and our fears and
our anxieties about the other,
but we're all the other.
We are the other.
Of course, we're mongrels.
That's what's so
absolutely wonderful.
PROFESSOR MICHAEL WHEELER:
This has, in some ways,
always been
a multicultural society.
It's more evident now,
because of obviously
the end of empire
and the whole impact
of a Commonwealth
and all of those things.
It's been very
interesting to see
how many people have been
very keen to live in Britain.
Is it just about there
being a national health system
and there being
a social security system,
of a kind that
you certainly don't get
in the United States?
No, it's about more than that.
It's about
people being attracted
to certain assumptions
about the way we live.
I come--
My family come from Ireland.
We know all about wanting
to be accepted as foreigners
in this country.
It takes a while,
but we do integrate,
we do welcome people
from abroad.
We always have.
Churchill?
-He was half American.
-FRANK MANNION: Hm?
He was half--
His mother was American.
Well, maybe that's
quintessentially British
that in fact
you're not local at all,
you're an invader
or an immigrant
or started from
somewhere else, why not?
I love the idea of this country
being multiracial,
which it gloriously is.
In an ideal world,
I like the sense
that anybody could
consider themselves to...
call Britain home,
because I think that its--
At its best when it celebrates
how cosmopolitan it is.
I get frustrated
when British people think
we're not inclusive and that
we're not all embracing,
because from what I've seen
from my travels, is that we are.
We really are.
FRANK MANNION:
Your surname is Petrucci.
Mm-hm.
FRANK MANNION:
Is that an English surname?
It's Italian. Sicilian.
My Grandad.
Launer is
a truly British company
and I'm very proud of the fact,
because of course my background
was originally from Germany.
Jacob Dege came
over from Germany in 1855.
My great-great-grandfather
was also a tailor in London.
His son and Mr. Dege's,
or now it's pronounced Dege,
their two sons got on very well,
so they actually
started up on their own.
Culturally, I think
because of the richness
of people's experiences
from the Caribbean, from India,
from Africa, from Europe
obviously makes it far richer
and there is really
something for everyone.
Oh, we are in
Chinatown, phenomenonal.
Amazing place, yes.
It's a good place to mix
with British culture
and international
culture and Oriental,
Chinese culture as well.
There's so many
Indians over here
and I don't feel
like I'm an outsider.
I feel like
I belong to this place.
British Asians are definitely
a huge part of Britain
with our cuisines, with
our commerce, with our cricket.
There are a lot
of dishes in our culture
to have worth celebrating that.
JAMIE HARRIS:
When I was retraining my career
in horticulture, Leonardslee
was kind of spoken of
in hushed terms then,
it was the lost hidden gem,
it was shut for, you know,
eight to ten years.
Ironically,
for a quintessentially English
woodland garden,
it was saved by
a South African-born family.
So Penny Streeter
and her family bought it,
reopened it
and are driving it forward,
making it what it is today.
Elgar was--
He was often considered
quintessentially English,
but a lot of his influences
were European.
It's not unusual
for foreign influences
to find their way into British
culture or British society.
Same is true of cricket.
It probably originated
in South East England,
but there is a competing theory
which suggests the game
was imported by Flemish weavers,
who arrived in this country
in the 16th and 17th century.
So, foreign influences
have made their way
into English cricket,
just as they have
into every other aspect
of British life.
Britishness, for me,
is not about being insular.
It's about being
open to the world,
absorbing influences and being
able, in turn, to influence.
And that, I think,
is one of the things
that makes us special.
PROFESSOR MICHAEL WHEELER:
Britain, 300 years old,
England, 1,100 years old.
They're very
different things historically.
They often say about England
that it's really the history
of the shires.
Back in the mists of time is
where we come from, as it were.
It's very interesting
that the British
are often called the English,
which extremely annoys members
of the other nations.
Now where I come
from is extremely English.
On all sides
of my family, English.
FRANK MANNION:
You have Irish ancestry as well.
I do.
FRANK MANNION:
Do you consider yourself
quintessentially
English or British?
[chuckling]
It's very interesting
you should ask that,
because I've just
done that programme
Who Do You Think You Are?
There is a huge slice of me
that is Irish.
And I was born in England.
And then there's a lot
of something elsewhere, as well.
I can't say anymore.
I'm like a kind of fruitcake.
IAN MCKELLEN:
Yes, and I discovered
when I did the same program
that I had
quite a recent relative
who was a professional actor.
I could feel myself
to be a Kiwi,
having worked there
for quite a lot.
Sean, born and bred
in Swansea in South Wales
and lived in
London most of his life,
still feels he's abroad
when he's in London.
I think I've brought
my Welshness with me
throughout my whole life,
everywhere I've been.
But I've lived in South Africa,
I've lived in America,
I've lived in England, so
I've lived all over the world.
And if you ask me in ten years,
I'll probably be clearer,
but at the moment,
I'm certainly
feeling very Welsh, yes.
Blood wise, I'm half Irish,
so I feel like
I'm a bit of everything.
But I guess
I quite enjoy playing up
to being a little bit
of a stereotype of somebody
who's English, but you know,
and sort of sounding posh,
but I'm not really posh either.
I just happen to have
a posh voice.
But my parents are
from South East London,
so they talk like that.
So I don't know what I am,
but I quite enjoy
playing a bit of a character.
And if I'm really feeling it,
I like to pretend
I'm in Downton Abbey.
That's usually when I'm at home.
Ooh, quintessentially British,
I think. Yes.
Yes, I'd like to think.
I think British is probably how
I would identify myself with,
purely and simply because
of the diverse nature
of where I'm from.
You know, my dad's from Jamaica,
my mum's from England and Wales
and you know
I think to encapsulate
as many of the islands
as I possibly can
and areas within myself,
that's why I would
probably call myself British
over just English.
English. Yes.
FRANK MANNION: Why?
Um... I don't really know,
to be honest.
British is a bit, maybe,
sensitive at the moment.
-English.
FRANK MANNION:
And why so decisively?
Why? Because that's our origin.
We are English.
Yep, definitely.
I feel I completely identify
as a very British person.
Yes, I'm very much a proud Brit.
Absolutely.
I'm from Monmouthshire,
the border of Wales,
so I think
I always sounded very English
to the Welsh people
and Welsh to the English people.
So I think I've always had
a slightly mongrelised
accent, so--
You're not born British,
you have it thrust upon you.
I would consider myself English,
though my parents
were both from Glasgow.
Yes, I think I do consider
myself quintessentially English.
I would consider myself British.
The connotations
of being considered English
are fairly negative,
I still feel.
I am English, I am British,
I am Congolese, I am Rwandan,
I'm a Christian,
I'm black, you know,
I'm happy to wear
that complexity with pride.
When people ask me
where I'm from,
I say I'm from the Caribbean.
Because like
I am and I'm very proud
to be from the Caribbean.
I am English and proudly English
and I am Irish
and proudly Irish.
Quintessentially British,
I've never thought
of myself as English.
I think we're a generation
that have grown up
being Brits rather than...
English in a way.
If not more European.
I am English,
I was born in England.
But I also consider
myself British and to be honest,
in the current
political climate,
I consider myself European
as well.
I'm not allowed to say
I consider myself European.
Delete that bit from the--
I consider myself British.
I'm Lancashire
all the way through.
I'm Chorley all the way through.
We've got great sport,
we've got great food.
Morecambe Bay Shrimps,
Bury Black Pudding,
Uncle Joe's Mint Balls
from Wigan.
With all this coming out
of Lancashire,
we have so much to offer.
So what do I call myself?
A Lancastrian.
Proud to be a Lancastrian,
proud of my accent,
proud of the North of England.
And of course, yes I'm English.
But I'm British as well.
And I represent a parliament
that covers the United Kingdom
and that matters to me.
So of course, yes,
I am British, I am English,
but I'm a true Lancastrian.
I was born in England.
I have a deep attachment
to England.
But I want to be part
of an internationalist future,
not an English past.
I spent a lot of my school days
and university time being taught
that nationalism had
been a very bad, narrow thing
which was now extinct.
And yet we now see a new
brand of narrow Englishness
that I think is terribly sad.
And I think it should be
possible both to celebrate a,
yes, quintessentially British
or quintessentially English
occasion like this
without wanting to take
the whole country
into standing on
the white cliffs of Dover,
giving two fingers
to Johnny Foreigner.
Okay?
If I go home and tell my wife
that I've ended up
talking about spies,
she'll just roll
her eyes completely,
because that's one of my--
I actually write spy fiction
in my spare time.
[laughing]
And it bores her to tears.
My immediate predecessor
as Master of Pembroke,
was Sir Richard Dearlove,
who had been head of MI6,
known as C rather than M
in the James Bond films.
So, yes, there have been people
from the world of espionage
or counter-espionage here,
but only in an official capacity
these days.
We did have a previous Master
who was burned at the stake.
I hope this isn't a pattern
that will be repeated
for present and future Masters.
I think Frank, it's gin o'clock,
so it's been so nice
meeting you.
And then this is what we have
very much enjoyed...
creating, making,
and then drinking.
Mind you,
it was four years of making
and it was nine months
of tasting gin.
FRANK MANNION:
Can you think
of any Shakespearean expressions
off the top of your head?
"Alas, poor Yorick!
I knew him well."
Not me.
[laughing]
-That's good, Fred, eh?
-Not bad.
I'm educated, bruv.
London taxi driver, see?
We know a bit about everything,
a bit about everything.
I like to use,
"Therein lies the rub,"
when I'm often making
a joke about something where,
you know, it just
maybe doesn't work properly
or whatever is not a big deal.
"Therein lies the rub."
But of course,
you know, when it was used
in a play originally,
it was for a very,
very tragic situation, you know,
probably something
life and death,
it usually is in Shakespeare.
"To be, or not to be,
that is the question."
"Wherefore art thou Romeo?"
"She who doth protest," you know
that sometimes gets said
in a bit of a joking way
when you're like,
"Well, I'm really not bothered
about this, but..."
Personally,
I didn't like Shakespeare.
You know,
the British have Shakespeare
and us Chinese have Confucius.
"Though this is madness,
there is method in it."
"Such sweet sorrow."
It's like, she sells
seashells on the seashore.
The shells she sells
are seashells, I'm sure,
but if she sells seashells
on the seashore,
then I'm sure she
sells seashore shells
and I bet
Ian McKellen can't do that.
Shakespeare knew and said often
through his characters that,
"All the world's a stage,
"and all the men
and women merely players."
We're all acting.